my three biggest concerns
uh as it relates to the colorado river
uh quickly are uh
you know we could see a pattern where we
become even more dependent upon
groundwater systems our aquifers
many of which throughout the desert
southwest
hold water that is tens of thousands of
years old from the uh from the last ice
age and so if if we become more reliant
on that we have to understand that we're
becoming more reliant on water from the
ice age once that's pumped it won't come
back and because we are seeing changing
precipitation patterns changing runoff
patterns
the aquifers that do get recharged from
present-day precipitation
uh they're not going to be recharged in
the way the way that they used to be
so how we use groundwater
is of paramount importance to me
number two
i think we have to as a nation
uh learn to respect and recognize
the
water and food nexus
i think a lot of folks don't realize
that the majority of our winter produce
is grown with colorado river water in
places uh like yuma arizona and imperial
county
um i think the uh the big question is
about the relationship with cattle feed
that is grown in those places and you
know there is obviously a big desire by
by many folks to uh to get a lot of that
uh out of the ground to free up water to
help prop up our reservoirs but i think
the question is is are we going to use
that to prop up our system are we going
to be trading it off for things like
suburban sprawl for for growing las
vegas even more for growing phoenix even
more for growing l.a even more so
we need to have a serious conversation
about how our food has grown with what
water it's grown where it's grown and if
we do decide to follow fields in the
desert southwest where will we be
growing uh the nation's uh supply of
nutrition to to offset the losses
uh third
i think we need to be talking about
climate change in in a very serious way
and if we keep ignoring the fact that
climate change is water change
we are just rearranging the deck chairs
on houseboats at lakes mead and pal
we have to understand that we have seen
massive reductions in flows in the
colorado river
over the past 20 years we've seen 20
percent decline we are likely to see an
additional 20 percent decline in flows
in the coming years
and we have to understand that
uh man-made systems anthropogenic
climate change human-caused climate
change is exacerbating that and driving
that
and until we figure out how to really
cut emissions in a serious way i know
congress has taken some recent actions
to do that but congress has also taken
recent actions to
lease uh every year an additional 62
million acres for oil and gas leasing
so
we we inherently contradict ourselves
i'm hearing inherent contradictions and
everybody's talking points on the river
and uh and so we got to come to grips
with with reality but i think those
three things understanding groundwater
understanding our food supply and
understanding how climate change impacts
all of that if we're not paying special
attention to it you know we could be
making
three giant mistakes